so I did a story a little over a week
ago about what I'm calling the trend of
softy monetization on YouTube that we've
been experiencing in the last month or
so and what I met by softy monetization
is that our channel is allowed to run
ads and to make money on YouTube but
more and more individual videos are
being flagged as potentially not brand
safe or sometimes age restricted which
isn't a demonic aliy ads stop running on
those videos and we make no money from
them and this was a major topic at the
conference that I was at in Las Vegas
last week I was talking to a lot of
other progressive hosts and I don't want
to say people are panicking but there
was a lot of concern about the viability
of the shows going forward and there are
two really important articles from the
last week about what's going on and it's
really really bad one article is from
the verge and it's called the Golden Age
of YouTube is over the other article is
by CNBC and it's about a copyright
overhaul in Europe which could crush
youtube and facebook video publishers
which we are and many other independent
progressive shows also are I want to
first deal with the copyright issue
because it's simpler the European Union
has a new copyright directive and it's
called one piece of it it's called
article 13 even though it's actually
17th now in terms of how its numbered
but it's still called
article 13 in any case the number
doesn't exactly matter because what it
does is what matters and it makes tech
firms liable for copyright breaches they
will have to get licenses from rights
holders in order to be able to host
content and I'm gonna explain to you in
really simple terms why this is such a
disaster if I upload anything to YouTube
that could be somebody else's work
previously even right now if there was a
copyright strike or a claim because we
violated someone else's copyright we as
the publishers would be liable now that
was bad enough and it came with a huge
set of issues including bogus and
aggressive copyright enforcement and a
whole bunch of other problems but under
article 13 if I publish something to
YouTube and I'm
violating someone else's copyright or
allegedly violating someone else's
copyright YouTube as the host of the
video Facebook as the host of the video
could be legally liable and that's a
level of risk that YouTube and Facebook
are not going to want to take and the
prediction is that it's going to lead to
pre-emptive deletion and censorship of
content before it even publishes and if
you thought YouTube was risk-averse two
years ago during ad pocalypse when
advertisers were threatening to pull
money out of YouTube just wait until
Google and Facebook can be liable for
the copyright violations of the people
that are posting the video so that's a
potential disaster it's just Europe for
now but it could grow Europe makes up
about 18 percent of our YouTube audience
so this means that overnight if the
article 13 implied policy is applied
aggressively we lose a fifth of our
YouTube revenue I mean just poof gone
crushing because of this new article 13
copyright directive that is happening in
Europe we'll see how that plays out
legally the second issue is the one laid
out in Julia Alexander's article in The
Verge once again it's called the Golden
Age of YouTube is over which I encourage
you to read and she does a really great
job of going in-depth on this but for
our purposes the key point is that
YouTube is effectively going mainstream
and corporate with its content if I had
to sum up in one sentence what's going
on YouTube used to prioritize
independent content like ours as they've
raised more and more money they've
poured more and more of that money into
traditional what they call brand safe
content and a lot of that content is
being produced by the same corporate
media platforms and celebrities that
everybody already knows and the gist of
what continues to happen on YouTube is
that there's going to be more of this
because it's just safer for YouTube if
YouTube wants to complete compete with
Netflix which they seem to want to do
they believe they need to be less about
independent productions like ours and
more about really safe legacy stuff and
this is just a disaster for us I would
actually argue
you that this is the worst four channels
in our position what we would call
medium to large YouTube channels we're
not in the five million subscriber range
but if you're a tiny subscribe YouTube
channel like 4,000 subscribers 10,000
subscribers under one or two million
views a month you're probably already
not relying on YouTube in any serious
way to fund what you're doing if you're
in the top point one percent like the
five million subscribers ten million
subscribers and higher YouTube is
literally going out of their way to
cater to you so you're also fine we are
in the top 1% of YouTube channels right
those in the range of two hundred and
fifty thousand to about a million
subscribers or so right now we have
about six hundred and twenty five
thousand subscribers we're big enough
that we're seriously invested in YouTube
as a platform and to some degree we rely
on it but we're not big enough that
YouTube sees us as the most worthy
investment and we even are considered
risky in some sense because of the
content that we might publish so we're
effectively in a great position to be
totally blindsided again one of the ways
we're seeing this happen and this is how
YouTube can very quietly crush producers
like us is that we are coming up less
and less in what's called YouTube's
discovery discovery is as you click
around YouTube if you're watching other
videos other videos are suggested to you
on the right sidebar or down below if
you're on mobile the frequency with
which our channel is appearing in those
suggested videos has been slowly
declining throughout 2019 when you
search for a video on YouTube the
frequency with which our videos show up
in that first or second page of results
has been slowly but surely declining
over 2019 and in fact that has gone from
being more than 40 percent of our views
to around only 30 percent of our views
and it keeps dropping that's nearly a
million views a month that we are losing
to those algorithm changes we have no
control over this so what we're doing is
we're not standing around twiddling our
thumbs I want to be positioned not to
have to rely on YouTube we were in a
rough spot after 2017 SD monetization so
we're working on updates to the mem
platform we're working on updates to the
offerings or paid subscriptions we're
pushing people to support us via
membership versus other platforms
YouTube takes a big cut of our YouTube
memberships patreon takes a full five
percent on our membership platform the
only cost is the 2.9 percent payment
processing fee which comes out of
payments that's almost all of the money
getting directly to us we're only
talking about a couple of bucks a month
we're talking about amounts of money
that most people not everybody in the
audience and I understand that most
people in our audience don't think twice
about spending a few bucks on a coffee
spending a few bucks on a beer and it is
quite literally our primary funding
source so I'm asking for your support to
prevent another ad pocalypse to prevent
another ad pocalypse from crushing us
the normal prices are six dollars a
month or sixty for the year I get that
that's a lot of money for some people
for two dollars and eight cents a month
you can be a member if you select the
$60 a year membership and apply the
coupon code save 35 it'll drop it to 25
bucks which is two dollars and eight
cents a month you can also apply the
code
this is 2022 any membership and it'll
save you 40% read the Articles that I
mentioned we're linking to them in the
description to the YouTube clip for this
story sign up if you can afford it this
is a really important time and a lot of
discussions in Las Vegas last week about
how can we position ourselves so that we
can actually say doesn't matter what
happens on YouTube
losing search traffic losing discovery
traffic losing monetization on videos we
don't have to care because we've built a
sustainable additional funding source
that's what we're all trying to do and I
am humbly asking that you consider the
circumstances and if the show is
important to you if it's not click away
you probably already have but if the
show is important to you if you think
progressive independent media matters
and you don't want this to be beholden
to what YouTube chooses to monetize or
not monetize sign up at wwlp.com it'll
make a really big difference